some of the big points coming out of a
very hectic monday first there are
reports that the big ten and the pac-12
are planning to cancel their season
there's also news of a
soon-to-be-released study about
long-term heart issues related to covet
19 which is prompting this concern from
the power five conferences right to not
go forward reports that both the sec and
the acc vow to play in this vague
suggestion that some of the big ten
schools may join
the sec or the acc
for a season i have a feeling that may
violate the charter documents that
brought them into the conference in the
first place but that's a different issue
in a pandemic players and coaches are
banging on the hashtag we want to play
uh bandwagon and now you've got
politicians who are getting involved
including the commander-in-chief who
tweeted yesterday play college football
and also retweeted the trevor lawrence
list of demands including the eventual
development of a college football
players association which we can only
assume
although it may not be an accurate
assumption means that the president
favors the organization of college
football players for the purposes of
securing more fair treatment better
rights and ultimately compensation for
their efforts i mean that's really the
takeaway that that that tweet from
trevor lawrence and others is so perfect
because it lures you in with we want to
play it gets you to sign on until you
read it for some they read it like oh
we're not so sure about any association
or organization i like when they have a
voice but that's too much of a voice
whoa step back there yeah that was way
too that's a tool out of a voice your
voice your voice should only be this we
want to play that's it nothing else all
right here's the topic that we want to
play well yeah and you know this is one
thing i do wonder here
do justin fields trevor lawrence realize
what they did there that you know i
understand they want to play and they're
united and all that
do they realize though that they backed
some sort of you know union type talk
there
or were they pawns in just a bigger play
here and they're just going hey we want
to play this sounds good we're united
yeah we'll put this out there get us
some safety rules was it intended to be
that way i guess is my question do we
know the answer to that
we don't know yeah but my guess would be
that
that
for the same reason that it's not
immediately obvious when you read it
when you look at it when you see it
right that it is
an unconditional unequivocal statement
of intent to play with some significant
exceptions yes i think the exceptions
were lost on a lot of people including
some of the players who retweeted that
agreement but all that matters yeah all
that matters from the player's
perspective according to the
powers-to-be is that they want to play
and i've been trying to think of a good
example here's an example i'm going to
give you and and it just demonstrates
how idiotic it is to just say well hey
the players want to play let's play
let's say there's a a group of kids who
want to commemorate their high school
graduation by going skydiving
and their parents
are very concerned about the safety of a
bunch of high school graduates probably
very hungover going skydiving the next
day sure and they're debating it and
they're discussing it and they're you
know the pros and cons and should we
really do this and maybe we shouldn't do
this and just as they're getting ready
to conclude that the kids should not go
skydiving the kids say but we really
want to and then they say okay fine you
really want to fine go ahead go despite
our misgivings despite our concerns
despite the fact that we're the adults
in the room that need to make this
decision you want to do it so go ahead
and do it i mean that it's an extreme
example of risk but it's the same idea
the whole purpose of the coaches the ads
the university presidents the conference
commissioners is to protect these kids
from their nature their nature is to go
play football and not think about the
risks that's why they go to the house
parties that's why they're doing things
that are unsafe they're not sitting down
and understanding the nuances and the
subtleties of what the problems may be
including chris the idea that every
college football program becomes a super
spreader potentially in the community if
you don't have every i dotted and every
t crossed as it comes to testing and
contact tracing and all your safety
protocols and maybe michigan and jim
harbaugh shocker he wants to play
football yeah michigan
maybe michigan is doing it right but
that doesn't mean everybody else is
doing it right no so it's not i i think
it's reckless
and and it's convenient
for
everyone who who stands to lose a bunch
of money if college football doesn't
play to glom onto this idea that well
the kids
really want to play they hashtag they
want to play well there's something to
that though there is something to that
you know i i will say that like just a
button it's effective well yes
and it's it's real you know it is like
jim harbaugh i don't think is like hey
listen you know i don't like jim
harbaugh we know that right that's been
well stated i also don't think he's like
some sort of jerk that doesn't care
about society and wants to be one of
those super spreaders i know you're not
trying to imply that or anything like
that either no no nor do i harbaugh's
flaw is this harbaugh says we're doing
everything great here at michigan how
the hell does he know everybody else is
doing everything that that's fine that's
the millionaire you're right
if if jim harbaugh had been in charge
and maybe he should have been of the
national college football program on
testing and contact tracing and
responsible activity and all that stuff
if they'd put him in charge of that
maybe we'd be fine right now there was
no one in charge of that that's part of
the problem well you're right there is
there's no governing body whether we
want a you know a union a governing body
something like that we want somebody to
take charge and do something here yeah
michigan i mean there's a reason they're
michigan and they're one of the the best
schools in the history of our country
you know not only in football but
school-wise it's a you know it's an
unbelievable university a lot of smart
people there jim harbaugh too is a smart
person you know i do think he cares
about his team too and i think the
president
of some of these schools care about
their players too
yes maybe they don't haven't drawn out
the plan yet to protect
these players and have something to go
forward to where we can like latch onto
and go okay that makes sense that makes
us feel better about it that's what
we're lacking here but i do think like
it's not about money for a guy like
harbar saban they're just psychos they
want to coach football and they care
about their kids who they know went
there a majority of them to play
football and maybe at one point have
that dream of being an nfl football
player and of course this is all
affecting some of that stuff too so i
don't think it's coming from a place of
malice with like some of these guys i
guess is what i'm trying to say right
off the bat there no no yeah ma mouse
are two different things yeah yeah yeah
and and and even if there isn't a
financial motivation because i'd like to
think that definitely sabin and most
likely harbaugh don't need the money at
this point absolutely they still have a
selfish motivation in that they want to
coach football they want this to happen
and
you've got too many people with
subjective self-interests who are
chiming in here and trying to warp and
twist this thing and it's becoming like
every other issue in society where you
can make a strong argument for or
against i just think
it's
both predictable and unfortunate that
that all of a sudden the notion that the
kids want to play is overwhelming the
conversation because it leads toward the
end that the people who have the
self-interest in seeing the games played
want to realize they want it to be
played and hey what we did we hey why'd
we wait so long to just say let the kids
play because they want to play yeah look
chris here's the thing
as you've said and as we've pointed out
there isn't the national mechanism to
ensure uniformity to ensure safety to
ensure that everything will be done
properly so
who cares if the kids want to play again
this gets back to the grown-ups in the
room this is where the grown-ups have to
say well kids we know you really want to
do this but you know the the parachutes
haven't properly been inspected we need
to make sure that there's a backup we
don't know anything about the guy who's
going to be flying you to the drop point
we got to look into all that and you're
planning on leaving tomorrow morning at
8 a.m
we don't have time to do it i mean that
that's what the responsible response
should be at this point we really
respect the fact that you want to play
but we've kind of had our heads up our
butts for the last five months nobody's
stepped up to provide any type of a real
plan for ensuring that everyone's going
to be safe not just the players but
their family members yeah anybody else
who may show up at games if they're
going to allow spectators other students
on campus people are going to let me
tell you they're going to show up and
they're going to tailgate and good luck
keeping them out right college football
town even on a day when there isn't
fans allowed and the stadium is still
going to be overrun by college football
fan i guarantee you as long as hotels
are open and roads are open college
football fan is going to be in
tuscaloosa knoxville and everywhere else
on college football game day even if
they can't get into the stadium so look
these are the broader considerations
that the grown-ups have to deal with
yeah the kids want to play football i
would too you would too 18 19 20 years
old what's the big deal let us go play
we've been putting the hay in the barn
and now you're gonna burn the barn down
okay but grown-ups need to be doing
things and the problem is they haven't
well that's all i was gonna say so
you're saying all these things but
they're not the grown-ups are not on
that side of the story i mean whether
it's you know the governor of
mississippi telling you know the the
public to wear a mask because he wants
to watch college football i mean that
just tells you first off it is part of
their culture down there and you know
sec acc country certainly you know mike
there's a part of me here in this
conversation that almost wants to just
go go ahead play
go let's see what happens go ahead no
nobody in the country is listening to
any of the rules the regulations the
guidelines anyways well i mean we're so
so i don't like okay clemson you want to
play football you want to roll the dice
on you know maybe somebody a part of
your organization dies maybe a player
does you know you want to deal with
those you know financial ramifications
if it starts being a super spreader in
your community and people do sue you
like you mentioned yesterday which i'm
sure is going to be a very real
possibility if that happens you know i'm
at the point now where i'm just i'm sick
of like i'm exhausted i'm talking about
it all the time and if these see that's
what they want i know they do they want
us to throw our hands in the air and say
go ahead and do it sure that's what they
want yeah i i get it so
i i would hope that they have enough
human decency to put some protocols in
place here if they really want to make
it happen
then okay go ahead make it happen like
you're going to take all the
responsibility though and the fallout if
a disaster happens and no no no no no no
no
we we were trying we were just trying to
do the right thing don't hold us
responsible for our own negligence or
recklessness we're just trying to do the
right thing but you know you're not
gonna hold up at some point i mean
that's not going to know and chris
we made this point yesterday in pftot if
you haven't seen it go and watch it
we're not going to go all the way down
that rabbit hole now but i'm convinced
that there are real liability concerns
here that the legal system will be
revolutionized by the processing of the
covet 19 cases that will be brought by
people who say to businesses and
organizations you shouldn't have
conducted that event you shouldn't have
been open you shouldn't have done this
and the more resources the business or
the organization have
the the greater
the chance that you're going to be
targeted and the greater the chance that
you're potentially going to spend a ton
of money and the two choices are this
the money that you lose from not playing
college football this season versus the
potential financial losses that could
extend for years if not decades cleaning
up the mess of pressing forward and
creating that mini super spreader event
that infects sickens and potentially
kills
multiple people in your community you've
got to deal with that risk on top of the
risk of the money you're going to lose
this year so those are things that the
schools need to resolve but i the
momentum they don't seem to care about
that aspect of it no yeah we just we
want we want what we want right now i
want their money about tomorrow
when tomorrow comes yes right it'll be
someone else's problem when the crap
hits the fan it'll be someone else's
problem not mine i just want what i want
right now kind of sums up our current
american experience if you think about
it yeah nick saban chimed in yesterday
and he's become the highest profile
coach to bang on this drum of well you
know what
if we don't play football
they're not going to be any safer anyway
in fact they may be at more risk if we
don't have them in the structure of a
college football environment etc etc
again this gets back to the idea of how
responsible do you want to be for the
possibility that you are going to be
exposing these players coaches staff
members and others to covet 19. do you
want to have the organized effort where
everyone is there and they're
potentially transmitting the virus among
each other or do you say hey go about
your business go about your lives we're
not responsible for what happens to you
and again if you've got a program chris
that's fully buttoned up and everything
is working right and you don't have
positive tests so the positive tests are
few and far between you haven't had to
shut down your training program if
everything is working at your school
then that has appeal okay the problem
here isn't that we can point to michigan
or this school or that school it's the
fact that the and the evidence has been
there of all the programs that have shut
down over the course of the past couple
of months there isn't that national
approach like the nfl has that we can
feel confident is going to number one
get it together and number two hold it
together for the duration of a fall
football season no well i mean there's a
lot here and okay i think the first
thing is with saban i mean there's
another great example i mean he does he
cares about his players of course i know
he's you know somewhat self-serving he
wants to compete he's you know in the
running for one of the greatest the
greatest college football coaches of all
time now
i agree with them that you know i do
think these players are probably better
off in that structured environment you
know where they're being watched over
okay hey we're eating here we're
practicing here here's the meeting
you're sleeping here college football if
they could get their crap together
like the sec let's just take them for
instance and i can't remember how many
teams in the sec what is it 14 total i
think it's 7 and 7.
they could have 14 bubbles i mean you're
not going to have kids in school most
likely so you can have your own bubble
and make this happen to a degree now now
also i understand the risk you're
talking about the coaches the people are
part of these college organizations
listen they signed up for this and a lot
of them want to do it right now we're
not hearing any of them like clamor to
get out or oh i don't feel safe about
this and i think nick saban the jim
harbaughs of the world if they have a
coach that's like i don't feel good
about this they're not like you know
banging the game wired they're not wired
they're not wired to do that no i know
they're not that they're they're going
to die in the saddle they are dying
you're right you're if they die you're
right you're exactly right it's just the
type of human beings that that football
attracts so there's that aspect of it
and then you know i don't know maybe if
they could figure out these little
college bubbles have a testing procedure
right and then also ensure
that hey we're staying in our bubble for
the college football season and co you
know we're gonna do college via zoom or
however they plan on doing that
if they go out into society and it
starts to spread and be that type of you
you're done like you it should be like
they need to set up guidelines like that
like you're done like i ask for you know
if an nfl team has a bunch of players to
test positive for covet and they can't
play no we're not rescheduling the game
you lose the other team did it right
they were ready to play you didn't you
lose i think they should do the same
thing with the sec oh wait we found out
contact tracing that you're starting to
spread it through alabama and things
like that hey alabama you're done for
the year we can't trust you move them
off go on to the next teams in the sec
if they want to pull it off maybe that's
viable i don't know
great point they should have been doing
this in march no doubt no doubt right
not while they're trying to paste it
together while the car is moving or
trying to change the tire on the moving
car as it rockets towards september and
and look the the
the picture that that you've painted
chris yeah it's compelling
i think it would work thank you think
about this
the
uh there's a butt to this
i knew that college football teams can
be the only you said
they're gonna have online only classes
right the college football team is going
to be the only kids on campus they're
going to have on lockdown in a hotel for
football season yeah that's all fine
right that's all great that's good
that's good but you're not paying them
no that's the problem
the more that you go to extreme measures
to hold these pieces of your billion
dollar machinery in place for football
season the more glaring it becomes that
they don't get paid because you are
adding to the risk you are adding to the
responsibility you are adding to the
burden you're adding to the sacrifice by
saying to that 18 19 20 year old kid
you're gonna live in this hotel room all
year long you're not leaving we'll bring
you your food you're here the only time
you leave is when we go to football
practice and then when you leave
football practice you come back here and
once a week we're going to go play a
game and then you're going to come back
here and you're not leaving there's
going to be people at every door no one
gets in no one gets out fine yeah if
you're getting paid for it if you're not
getting paid for it and and this is
where the we get to the water's edge of
but they get an education
no you can't justify locking these kids
down for four months and not paying them
and that's a bridge the university
presidents don't want to cross yesterday
the notion that they're far more
petrified about the idea that these kids
are now going to be organized and seek
representation than they are about the
virus which is a short-term problem
the robots becoming self-aware is a
long-term problem that threatens to blow
up the entire model and force budgets to
be completely restructured to account
for the fact that god forbid we're
paying the guys that people are paying
to watch mike i i mean i'm glad you took
took uh the conversation there because i
think right i mean if
they're gonna do all the things that i'm
trying to say right the this case i'm
trying to set up where you want to play
football sec acc here you go
okay
i agree with you they almost need to
come out in front of it and go listen
yeah we need college football we need it
for our tv money we need it for our
school to survive
and we're going to
you know up the ante with what we give
college football players especially this
year during the covet 19 risk and the
thing they're doing there and go forward
trying to find a way to compensate them
better and you know i don't know whether
that is i don't know if a union is
really realistic
with you know college kids who are
leaving after two after three years four
years all the time like that but damn
can we set up a governing body something
like that that has to be like call the
old heisman guys like eddie george matt
leinart you know doug flutie get them
onto some panel and they'll figure out
the best way to protect some of these
college kids those are the kind of kids
kind of people that like college
football and those kids it just yeah the
problem is it goes back to what the hell
has everybody in college football been
doing for the last six months just
twiddling their damn thumbs i mean i'm
just i'm amazed that this is where we're
at in this conversation in the middle of
august it's unbelievable well
two things two things chris they were
listening to and buying into talk that
it will just one day magically blow away
i don't know where i've heard that it'll
just disappear we'll wake up one day and
it'll be gone and theoretically that
that that that's true maybe because
we'll be gone but either way one day it
eventually will be gone but secondly i
think that they didn't want to start
down that path because the thing is the
more you put on the players the more
restrictions the more restraints the
more structure we get closer and closer
to this moment of reckoning that college
football has been fending off for the
last 10 years or so since people started
to realize this probably isn't fair to
the kids and i think the people in
charge recognize you know what
eventually this is going to blow up on
us but until it does let's grab all the
money we can let's make as much money as
we can we don't have to pay the kids
let's hold on to this as long as we can
and the last point
is that god it was a good point too uh
and it's just it just disappears oh it
happens oh here it is here it is i got
it i got it i got it um you mentioned
unionization yeah northwestern tried
that several years ago right it doesn't
work it doesn't fit within the laws
created by congress to allow for workers
to unionize so
the answer
is in the same federal legislative body
that created the national labor
relations act and everything else that
sets up the unionization of employees
the way to fix this is to get congress
to say
enough
to get congress to create a law that
gives these players rights that requires
them to be paid in the first step in
that direction we've seen the
proliferation of the name image and
likeness laws allowing college football
players to make some money off of who
they are while they're still amateur
athletes just like olympians can do and
i think the next step is and again the
reckoning is coming getting to the point
where they get a piece of the revenue
that they generate and uh you know and
this is the this is the kind of moment
that can accelerate yeah okay and i
think that's part of what they're trying
to fend off chris but uh look
wherever we are now i i feel like there
is a determination by multiple
conferences to get the season in even as
conferences like the big 10 and the
pac-12
are seriously considering and and by all
accounts already intend to to not go
forward and wouldn't it be weird if we
have a fall season with the sec in the
acc yeah
and then a spring season
with the big ten and the pac-12
i don't know what the big 12 is gonna do
i don't know you know and you know i
i've never been a fan of west virginia
being in the big 12. because i feel bad
for the kids in the non-revenue sports
that have to fly back and forth to texas
and oklahoma five six seven eight nine
times a year yeah when they're the ones
who are truly student athletes but uh i
i you know the big 12 seems to be kind
of caught in the middle between the
other four right now yeah well
you know
i think what we're seeing here is
you know yes a a play to make some
a way to play some football is what i'm
trying to say i understand it i have
sensitivity towards the kids the coaches
everything they want to do they need to
start showing some structure to show
they have sensitivity to make sure it's
done right to protect the kids society
all of those things listen we can't live
in this thing like live in fear of this
thing forever we got to push forward a
little bit but push forward and be
careful and that's what we're not
hearing with the ncaa right now you've
given us nothing to think you're being
careful or going to do things the right
way to protect all that's involved
and you know i'm okay with the football
players of america here being the guinea
pigs for this to push forward and kind
of break some barriers here i think most
football players are okay with that but
it's got to be done the right way and i
think that's what we're talking about
and we just haven't heard enough of that
yet
and and listen listen
living in fear i see i i
there's a difference between living in
fear and living in safety
and living and living and living within
the boundaries of the hand you've been
dealt chris i mean
we we've got like a seven high five hand
poker uh
you know our five card poker hand right
now so you know you got to play what you
have and the cards have not gotten any
better we've thrown back four and we've
gotten nothing back yeah so you've got
to operate within those boundaries and
you know we we're going to live in we're
going to live in concern
until they find a way to fix this that's
fine and we just have to try to navigate
around it all right let's take a break
if college football season ends up
moving to the spring
what does that mean for the national
football league what does it mean for
the draft the nfl watching and waiting
for college football to make a decision
because then the nfl is going to have
some decisions to make we'll talk about
that when pft live continues right after
[Music]
you